nevada task force which was sent to
louisiana to help with hurricane ida is
heading back home clark county officials
say the task force one mission is
complete after they assisted with clean
up efforts the nevada task force urban
search and rescue was activated by fema
and responded to baton rouge the team
included firefighters from clark county
henderson fire department north las
vegas and las vegas fire and rescue
turning to our coronavirus coverage
tonight 1400 new covid cases have been
reported statewide this increase has led
to a slight uptick in nevada's test
positivity rate it's now at 12.3 percent
hospitalizations in nevada are also up
just slightly meanwhile more than 52
percent of nevadans eligible for shot
are now fully vaccinated
new data from the american academy of
pediatrics shows more than 20 percent of
coronavirus cases reported last week
were among children cases and kids have
exploded since july from about thirty
eight thousand reported weekly to more
than two hundred thousand in all almost
five million children have tested
positive for covid19
[Music]
well for half the century las vegas has
been an untapped reservoir of college
football potential it's the perfect
destination for a neutral site showdown
a legion stadium is the perfect venue
kevin martin is live inside the palace
with a preview of this dazzling debut
game kevin
well john college football is back and
it feels absolutely amazing byu and
arizona are set to meet on the field
here at allegiant stadium in the vegas
kickoff classic now the wildcats come
into this matchup riding a 12 game
losing streak that's tied for the
longest streak active in college
football but they're looking to turn
things around on their first year head
coach jed fisher as they take on byu a
team that is 11-1 last season and
they're looking very confident coming
into tonight's matchup at 12 and a half
point favorites but people are saying
that this could be a trap game for byu
as they face their rival utah next week
so a good matchup on deck between
arizona and byu and the vegas kickoff
classic reporting live at allegiant
stadium kevin martin 8 sports now